why don't we speak next
to um oh i don't know why don't we go to
uh let's go to theodore from new york
city theodore you're on the air
i'm on the air is that right can you
hear me that's absolutely correct wow
what an honor thanks david thank you
um so i don't even know where to begin
um
i've been trying to leave a voicemail
about
a student loans there was a provision
under
the recent stimulus bill that
exempts taxes on forgiven loans for the
next five years
and some articles are headlining this as
though saying
this paves the way for uh biden's
executive action to forgive
student loans of x number of dollars to
what extent
should people who have uh student loan
debt
uh be anticipating executive action on
student loan i wouldn't be i wouldn't be
taking any action
that assumes anything will be done i
think it's very risky to make any
financial decision on the expectation
that there will be a certain change but
i'm not sure i understood what you said
it's you said something about taxes on
student loans or did you mean interest
on student loans can you just explain it
again to me
absolutely so if in the past if a
student loan was forgiven
you would pay taxes on the amount
forgiven you know when you file your
taxes every year it says
you know did you have any um loans
forgiven in the previous year
ah so in other words if you had 10 grand
forgiven it counts as 10 000 in income
is that the way it was i just don't know
about this provision
something along those lines so this
provision has stated that
if any amount is forgiven you won't be
taxed on it and i guess the rationale
for why this would lead to forgiveness
is because say there was some blanket
forgiveness people wouldn't be paying a
lump sum on their taxes for it
i see what you're saying yeah i mean it
sounds like a reasonable precursor but i
have no reason to think that that's what
it is and i would advise anyone from
making any
financial decision assuming that that's
what's coming
so if you were in the position to uh
just barely would you pay off your
student loan balance
well are you paying interest or are they
in forbearance
they're in forbearance but i just don't
like the idea of being in debt
well then that's the answer right there
i mean this is sort of like should you
pay off your mortgage early and you can
say well
if i put the money in the market i could
make seven percent and but at the same
time
you know the mortgage interest rate is
only 3.5 so that the answer would be no
don't pay the mortgage early put it in
put it in an index fund but there's a
psychological component
for getting rid of a debt that each
every person will value differently so
really you have to decide that that
there's no uh
there's no mathematical answer to that
makes absolute sense thank you yeah
all right my pleasure wow very meaty
questions today
very very strong